new in theaters this weekend Little
Women 1917 spies and disguise uncut gems
and just mercy what will you see this is
your weekend ticket
[Music]
you make it short and spicy and if the
main character is a girl
make sure she's married by the end Wow
in this adaptation of the classic novel
little women follows the March sisters
as they come of age in the aftermath of
the Civil War
this version is directed by Greta Gerwig
who made Lady Bird another coming-of-age
movie so it seems like a perfect fit
this movies for you if you're a fan of
the book you're looking forward to Greta
Gerwig steak or you're a little man
there's any one way this ends
Last Man Standing 1917 is the tale of
two British soldiers tasked with the
mission of delivering vital information
of an upcoming ambush across dangerous
territory in World War one this movies
for you if a war movie sounds good this
weekend you like a good based on a true
story movie or you realize the real
battlefield is hey Lance look at me look
at you I can see my butt and your face
at the same time that is so cool spies
in the sky sees a spike Oh perhaps too
deep undercover as he's turned into a
pigeon and now must work with the young
scientist to get the mission done the
movie stars Will Smith Tom Holland
rashida Jones Ben Mendelsohn Karen
Gillan and ding dong Khalid this movie
is for you of a family movie sounds good
to you this weekend you're a fan of
movies by Blue Sky Studios like Ice Age
or you've ever realized you can't say DJ
Khaled quietly Howard where's the money
right now
in a too late and another serious and
critically acclaimed role for Adam
Sandler uncut gems tells the story of a
jeweler whose gambling habits have put
his life into all sorts of danger and
pushed him to frantically keep it
together and keep his family safe this
movie is for you if a suspense movie is
what you seek this weekend you want to
see all the hype around Adam Sandler's
performance or your eyeballing that
Furby in the trailer oh my get that and
I'm gonna do everything possible to keep
them from taking you all know what you
into down here now better when you get
it from the moment you're born we don't
you a driven fledgling lawyer is set to
a volatile case and just mercy as you
must defend a man wrongfully accused of
the murder of an eighteen year old girl
in 1987 Alabama this movies for you if a
crime drama sounds good to you this
weekend you're a fan of the solid acting
a Michael B Jordan or you're a fan of
the solid acting of Jamie Foxx huh lucky
for you they're both in this film that
is your weekend ticket will let you see
and we'll see you in the next decade